you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with political
commentator polly mckenzie and john
stevens deputy political editor of the
daily mail they'll be with us from now
right up until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
putin's pawns that's how the metro
describes the two british men fighting
for ukraine who've been captured and
sentenced to death by the russians
the eye reports that the court
proceedings have been condemned as
nothing more than a show trial which has
sparked a diplomatic outcry
the telegraph pictures the two men in
their courtroom cage under the headline
captured british fighters sentenced to
death
this is the daily mirror on that story
sentenced to death by putin
barbamel says the uk is outraged at the
sentence
the guardian leads with the fuel cost
crisis reporting that low-paid care
workers can't now afford the petrol they
need to get to work
on the railways the times reports that
strike chaos is set to worsen as train
drivers join the stoppages
the financial times reports that
chancellor rishi sunak has been accused
by a leading economic research body of
squandering 11 billion pounds in
taxpayers money by paying too much
interest on government debt
while the sun pictures prince william
selling the big issue as the paper puts
it just like mum diana
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by political
commentator polly mckenzie and john
stevens deputy political editor of the
daily mail welcome to you both good to
see you let's start with the
metro and their front page the headline
there as we ran through the the
newspaper stack putin's pawns polly
well the foreign secretary is quoted as
saying that she is outraged by this
death sentence and i think that's how
most of us will be feeling
throughout this war it's been clear that
putin the russians and their allies
are not interested
in following the laws of war
uh you know there have been allegations
of all sorts of war crimes including
uh attacking civilians um the summary
execution of civilians of sexual assault
and rape against women and this is
another example of that violation of the
principles under which countries are
supposed to
remain um
you know to follow during times of war
and this donetsk people's republic is
not a state recognized by anyone other
than the russians russia itself doesn't
have the death penalty but they
uh it seems are endorsing this um
show trial essentially that of these of
these captured prisoners of war who
ought to be treated like prisoners of
war uh but they're not being treated
like prisoners of war they're not
interested in
as i say in in following the laws of war
and
the only hope
in a way
as the metro says is that because they
are putin's pawns because they are
leverage against the west of course our
foreign sector will be extremely
concerned
about the future of these two british
citizens as will the moroccan government
be
against the about the the fate of the
moroccan citizen
um
that potentially that means that this
this sentence won't be carried out
swiftly because it it will
give them some leverage against us i
think that's that's all we can hope for
at this point
and john the accusation is that they're
mercenaries but both men we know settled
in the country uh way before the
invasion
i think both of them went out to ukraine
in 2018
aidan aslin who is from newark in
nottinghamshire
he went out there to fight back then and
um sean pinner who is the um
guy who is from watford he actually
moved out there with his wife in 2018
moved to mario pole he's a former
british army soldier and then started
fighting at some point after the
invasion i think it was and so britain
is saying quite clearly these aren't
people who were mercenaries and it does
seem like this was a sham trial tom
tugan heart who's chair of the foreign
affairs select committee
he was on the radio early today and was
saying this is a complete sham trial
these weren't really judges these were
people dressing up as judges and
pretending to be as polly says they
don't have the death sentence in russia
and it seems quite possible that the
only way that these
guys manage to get out alive is if they
are used as a prisoner swap and that
putin uses them and says well we will
hand these over if you release some
russians who are accused of war crimes
in ukraine
yeah so we see them uh
photograph pictured at the front of the
the daily telegrapher and there has been
some mention that this is actually
what it really is is the start of
negotiations uh because there could be
some sort of prisoner swappers as john
saying polly do you think that is the
the likely
outcome of this scenario
i i think it is um they will certainly
be considering what leverage there is
huge numbers of russian soldiers
have been captured by the ukrainians
uh and and you know they have been
collecting evidence as john suggests for
a range of war crimes trials because
they are following due process and
collecting evidence and scrutinizing
that evidence that means they are
proceeding much more slowly so it does
seem that what uh the the separatists
and donetsk backed by putin are trying
to do here is in a way get
get ahead of the curve be first
with uh with their kind of criminal
process
so that they can potentially negotiate
the return of of prisoners on on the
other side you know i i'm it's important
that we keep even during a war lines of
diplomatic communication open
to minimize the harm to find ways to to
come to some sort of settlement or some
way to end this war
and we absolutely have to hope that
something like a prisoner swap is
possible
in order to protect the lives of these
men who you know essentially having
settled in ukraine were just like so
many ukrainian soldiers who we know have
also been captured or transported to
russia and you know we don't even know
their fate we're just simply fighting to
defend their homeland against a hostile
invasion
uh john does it come as any surprise
that the the uh normal conventions of
war as as they are are not being
followed at all in in this situation
well sadly not when it comes to putin we
know that he's done so many things for
propaganda purposes we know that after
they were captured they were paraded on
camera which is obviously one of the
things that you're not allowed to do
under the geneva convention is parade
privileges of war on camera so obviously
i mean it is shocking that
putin is breaking all of these
conventions but it's not really a
surprise when you see what else he's
been doing in ukraine over the last few
months and definitely years
uh polly what role do you think our
government has to play
well our government will be wanting to
open lines of communication uh around
these prisoners you know we know how
difficult it can be
uh we saw the years of negotiation it
took to return nazanin zagari ratcliffe
on in a way a much lesser charge not
threatened with a sentence of death from
iran when you have a government
which has you know kind of geopolitical
ambitions
and is using prisoners simply as
leverage with no regard frankly for
their humanity or their or their care
the reality is it can take an immensely
long time and what you don't want to be
as a government is in a way just sort of
creating incentives for the russians or
or in any kind of situation for people
to be taking hostages the sense that if
taking british citizens hostage uh
capturing them is a way to get
concessions from the united kingdom
government that kind of creates a a
really problematic kind of message for
the world so they need to be really
cautious about what is offered and i
think crucially remain in lock step as
we have done with the ukrainians in the
end you know any end to this war any
negotiation over prisoner swaps will be
have to be led by ukraine um because you
know it's it's their country which has
been invaded and it's for them to
determine the the you know any kind of
um concessions that they're willing or
not willing to make yeah but our
government quite vocal if you look at
the financial times uh foreign secretary
liz trust quoted as saying the judgment
says sham i usually condemn the
sentencing of aiden aslan and sean
pinner held by russian proxies in
eastern ukraine they're prisoners of war
this is a sham judgment with absolutely
no legitimacy um and that is that it's
the key that the area that we're we're
talking about where they have been put
on trial isn't even recognized john
no that's completely right and i think
you will see obviously ministers making
this case to russia i think it is
important that the ukrainian government
takes the lead in this because
obviously we are saying that they aren't
mercenaries they are people who have
moved to ukraine and settled there and
so it was legitimate that they were
fighting i think the uk government has
to tread a very difficult line when it
comes to this welcome back to you both
let's have a look at the daily telegraph
and this story um
it's lord frost who's saying that boris
johnson will be
ousted by autumn unless he changes
course and this is lord frost the former
brexit minister and uh erstwhile or
still is a boris johnson ally polly take
us into this story although it's very
critical doesn't sound like an ally
no i mean this is a classic of the lord
frost political strategy
in that what he says is what boris
johnson should do is stuff that makes
him lord frost very happy you know and
and that's really all he's been saying
for years um
is that boris johnson should do the
things that david frost likes and it's a
reminder i think of what the fragility
of boris johnson's position is pushing
him into lord frost represents
absolutely an important
wing of opinion within the conservative
party a sort of traditionalist stature
right low tax low regulation
the ones who wanted brexit to be
the the the unleashing of what they call
singapore on thames just you know
sort of let the markets rip
and stop government doing quite so much
the problem is that that isn't actually
what won boris johnson the 2019 general
election and that amazing majority it's
not what he's been trying to deliver
it's not actually what will win him the
next election because the coalition of
voters who supported brexit is much more
complicated they don't want a low tax
low regulation economy they want decent
public service they want infrastructure
investment and they want leveling up all
of which is quite expensive but if boris
johnson wants to shore up his position
with the crucial voters who can control
whether he's prime minister or not those
conservative back bench mps he probably
does have to do the stuff that makes
davis trust happy the problem is that
undermines his prospects of actually
being able to win an election because it
steers him massively to the right to the
appeal of the conservative back benches
and grassroots and away from
those voters who actually put them into
number 10.
uh john lawfrost is predicting an
attempt to to to oust him after the
conservative party conference in in
early october
unless he he calls for tax rises uh to
be reversed v80 on energy bills to be
slashed and also a ten year he's gone
over a ten-year conservative plan for
changing britain and he's not alone in
wanting these things within the
conservative party is he
no i think the comments that he's made
shows that the political risk that boris
johnson faces didn't go away after that
vote on monday we know there's a lot of
people in the tory party who are calling
for more tax cuts we know that the tax
burden in the uk is i think it's
possibly now its highest level in 70
years and you listened to boris johnson
in that speech today he was saying that
government can't spend its way out of
inflation and it can't tax its way to
growth but that almost seems like what
the government has been doing for the
last six months that you can see why
boris johnson now is coming under
pressure from people on his own side
people who want that cut in income tax
that's been promised for 2024 to be
brought forward to this year and i think
you're going to hear a lot more of this
when it comes to the budget in the
autumn i think it is quite probable now
that you see boris johnson doing
something to help people with personal
taxes you've already seen him have to
water down that rise in national
insurance they're rising the threat
raising the thresholds i think it's
later in this summer and so yeah you're
starting to see a bit of a mess on the
tax policy side that what the tories are
putting forward is starting to look
rather incoherent
very quickly polly i think we've got
about 30 seconds uh take us into these
uh smoking reforms that uh are
potentially
going to be coming in this in the
meantime
the goal
that the government's advisor javid khan
has set out is to make smoking obsolete
one of the great things is there's loads
of other ways to get nicotine which is
the addictive substance in cigarettes
but that does almost none of the health
harms that don't rely on burning tobacco
and inhaling a whole bunch of smoke and
tar into your lungs which is the thing
that kills you
and that means that we can move people
away from smoking to alternatives like
chewed tobacco or vaping um
in inhalators all sorts of things and so
the idea is to make it so that um some
teenagers will never be able to buy
cigarettes because instead of just a
team it just goes up every single year